Hey friends and welcome to the Riker Medical Podcast.
Riker Medical is a platform for education focused on emergency, transport, and critical
care medicine.
We believe that the sharing of knowledge should be free, accessible to all, and that innovative
use of technology can facilitate that effort.
This podcast is just one piece of that whole project.
Also, while we may mention medical treatments and interventions along the way, remember
that we are just strangers on the internet and don't do things you aren't allowed to
do.
For more information about the project, visit us at RikerMedical.com.
Today on the show we are going to talk about a project to get my good friend Claudel to
paramedic school in the US in order to become Haiti's first paramedic.
We are joined by another amazing human, Armadeus, who has helped Claudel in his EMS journey
over the past 10 years or so.
We had some technical issues getting Claudel linked into the call from Haiti, but you will
get the idea and his voice does eventually come through.
I opened this conversation up with a question to both Claudel and Armadeus about how they
know one another, but then we lost Claudel for a bit.
So we will pick it up with Armadeus responding to that question.
How do you guys, Claudel and Armadeus, know one another?
I will just talk about how, from my perspective, how we went.
So in 2010 there was a large earthquake in Haiti that occurred, 7.0, and it was devastating
to the country.
It ended up actually killing a quarter million people from what they can estimate, probably
more but confirmed around a quarter million people.
So I actually have been in the fire service as a firefighter paramedic since 1999 and
it had been to some disasters.
I went to Hurricane Katrina when that happened.
And then when the Haiti earthquake happened, it just kind of sent the same signals, if
you will, through my body where I just felt that need to go and help because I had some
of the skills to go do it.
So for Haiti, I kind of did the same thing for Katrina where I just started calling the
people in the industry that I know.
We put together a small team.
It was just actually six of us.
We flew down to Santo Domingo in the Dominican Republic, rented a van, and we had about 1200
pounds of medical gear with us that we had gotten through donations or gifts.
We basically made a point to drive into Haiti and help any way we could.
So that's kind of how all of this started for me anyway.
So did you meet Claudel in that first trip down there?
Yeah.
So we basically, we knew of a small group of people who were trying to get a field hospital
started and that was just through a phone network.
And we kind of got an idea of where it was and we pulled up Google Maps using GPS coordinates
and just kind of saw this little area where it was an old amusement park for kids and
it had these walls that were still standing and some covered structures and it just seemed
like a securable area.
So we drove into town, followed the satellite map directly to where we needed to go and
we showed up and started this field hospital and then Claudel had come in with a small
group of folks because they knew how to speak English.
So right after the earthquake, I think they were kind of looking for an opportunity to
help out and heard about us and what we were trying to do.
And yeah, they just showed up and started translating for us.
And that's how I met Claudel.
That's awesome.
Yeah.
And then subsequently, were you involved with the EMT training through MPAC down there?
So I actually started MPAC Northwest.
Oh, okay.
And so that was in 2010, it was just myself and a group of my friends.
So we had actually planned on just going down to Haiti for a couple weeks right after the
earthquake to help stabilize and then get out of there.
Because it was at that point, it wasn't a formal organization.
It was literally just, hey bros, we've been on a lot of stuff together.
You want to go get into this mess?
And that's kind of how it started.
So that's awesome.
Yeah.
And then the EMT training actually happened the following year because like I said, we
had planned on just being there for a couple of weeks and just people kept showing up at
the gates to be seen.
And we realized, holy crap, this is way bigger than what we initially thought.
And other small grassroots disaster organizations started showing up and then we all started
collaborating working together.
That lasted two weeks, turned into 12 months.
And we kept that field hospital running.
And we were about ready to leave after that first year is when all the translators approached
us and asked us about teaching them something before we left.
And it wasn't difficult.
I mean, aside from coordinating all the instructors to come down from the States and that was all
very difficult because we also had to raise the money to fly all the instructors down
there and housing and everything else too.
But yeah, so that's kind of how that started.
And then we graduated another class after that and we made sure that they all had jobs
and yeah.
And then 10 years goes by and I'm still trying to sort out how one little trip to go help
post-earthquake turned into everything that it has.
Yeah, it's amazing.
Yeah.
Hey, Claudel, you're back.
I don't know if you can hear us, but I'm just kidding.
Claudel, are you with us?
Yeah.
Hey, Claudel.
So I just told the entire story of how we met just in the beginning.
Yeah, so for people who maybe haven't worked overseas or gone traveling too much, this
is just kind of how it is, period.
Doing anything overseas.
It's just kind of Caribbean time, Caribbean technology.
You just got to wait.
Yeah, I remember when I was working down there trying to make phone calls back home.
Like it seems so simple.
You just like FaceTime someone or call them on WhatsApp.
I also had Skype on my phone.
You could use Google Voice.
I just had like all options and sometimes I would call somebody like four times from
each of these different mechanisms to try and finally get through to them.
Yeah.
The concept of multiple SIM cards in one phone.
Pretty awesome.
So when were you down there?
I was down there I think summer of 2018 till summer of 2019.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, you spent some time down there.
Yeah, I was working at Heydir Eminence with Claudel and I would spend like every other
month there.
So I think until I spent like seven or eight months down there.
Okay, cool.
But it was like off and on.
Yeah, so that's how he and I know each other.
Okay.
Yeah, and at the time when I was down there, we were trying to find a way to do med school
for our three EMTs there in Haiti.
But it proved to be pretty difficult.
They never quite panned out.
And there were some internal issues and kind of everything got put on hold for a while.
So yeah, this is a great backup plan for Claudel because the plan we were trying to get going
never actually happened.
Yeah, well, I mean, the same lessons we all learned is everything in Haiti is hard.
I think when you initially try to gauge a project, you kind of gauge it in American
terms, you know, how hard is it going to be to put on an EMT class?
Well, it's pretty hard in America, but you know, it's literally comes down to as from
the instructor perspective, it's, you know, you got to show up three nights a week and
give up a few weekends for two, three months.
And it seems doable, but then you try to translate that into how am I going to teach an EMT class
in Haiti with, you know, it's a 12 week program and you have, you know, 12 or 15 different
instructors you have to fly down.
And yeah, so it's pretty interesting how that works out.
I think it's definitely best to train a few paramedics in the States.
And then if there was, you know, to be a program to be developed down there, this is going
to take some time and there's obviously going to have to be a development of trust between
the national registry or the hosting university or whoever it is that's going to certify these
classes, these medics, right?
Right.
Yeah.
I mean, I think once there are a few Haitian paramedics who can get that experience in
the US or wherever else they get it from and then take it back there, I think that's the
key, especially because there's not really a robust 911 system to get that experience
like we have in other places.
Yeah.
I mean, I mean the good news is about these guys, Haiti Air Ambulance is generally, not
obviously, you know, not all the time, but generally people who require a flight are
pretty sick.
So at least having exposure to those cases in Haiti is, well, my hopes are that that
would be enough to keep these guys trained up.
And I haven't personally worked or flown for a, but from, you know, the visiting the site,
I mean, it's seems pretty squared away.
I would argue there might be some bases in the States that aren't as squared away as
that basis.
So man, it's a bummer.
It looks like we're not going to be able to have a cloud all with us, huh?
Yeah, I know.
It keeps coming and going.
Oh, we got you.
Yeah.
Hey, say something while you're here.
That is the next question.
I may.
Well, why don't you tell us about impact Haiti and how that all started?
Oh, impact Haiti started on 2011.
So and we got a sister organization, which is impact not 20.
OK, and then started, as I said, 2011 and Amadeus Davison.
That's where I met Amadeus Davison at Bojie Park.
So it came after the upgrade to here.
OK, and then we created that organization.
OK, and I am still part of impact Haiti and helping teaching first responder and then
EMT class.
OK, so in the past, we had, you know, impact not to us, but it was, you know, but for
now, we are like an hour on, you know, and trying to move forward.
OK, so still the same goal teaching.
And then helping, you know, yeah, but in the past, we used to do mobile clinic and then
several classes, you know.
Yeah, but I think we still got the same dream and praise the Lord Amadeus Davison.
So I think he's helping now by creating the website, OK, for impact Haiti.
And then we are trying to move on.
Yeah.
So impact Haiti and New Twist help us teaching the first EMT class.
OK, so when I graduated September 2011.
OK, and after the first class, we had two other classes, EMT classes I met.
And if you first responder classes, OK, yeah, and we still have the same dream.
We don't want to give up.
Yeah.
And do you guys have an idea of how many EMS providers, how many teams you guys have trained
in the last 10 years since you guys started?
OK, you want to answer this?
I'll tell you what, I'll give it a shot.
You can fill in the holes.
So the first two EMT classes that we trained were I think the first one was 14 students
and the second one was what, 18 students, Claudio, the second EMT class?
The second was Amadeus Davison.
It was about 25.
Oh, wow, wow, wow.
OK, yeah.
So the thing is, this kind of just grew, this whole thing grew organically because like
I said, we worked with essentially the first entire class of EMTs were the translators
that worked with us.
And I think if there's anything, whether it was intentional or not, when you join EMS
or pre-hospital or even medicine, there's just the general idea that we need to not
only learn, but also be educators.
And I think these guys took that on naturally and started teaching first responder classes
almost immediately after they had picked up their EMT lessons.
But to answer your question, I mean, we're in the several hundred first responders.
So EMTs, right, Claudel, something around there?
Yeah, they were around.
Yes, I agree.
Yeah.
And yeah, I'm just going to throw in there real quick.
It's a real mind melt to know.
Ten years ago, we just accidentally kind of put on this EMT class and then to show up.
I went down there earlier this year and spent some time with Claudel.
But to see these people in uniform and like huge turnouts, you know, 20, 30 students showing
up two, three times a week on their own dime, just out of commitment to the community.
It's really amazing to see.
So we're hoping to keep that going.
And, you know, to add to this incredible work that impact Haiti, Claudel and his cohorts
have been doing down there over the past decade, we're trying to create a scholarship program
through impact Haiti, where maybe after Claudel gets through, maybe we can send a second or
third or fourth medic to the United States for training or to develop enough funds and
a system where we can start actually teaching paramedic classes in Haiti itself.
That would be outstanding.
But that'd be awesome.
Yeah, that'd be all up to these guys to direct.
So so as far as Claudel going to paramedic school in the US, what's the what's the
status on that?
How do we have like a date of when we think it's going to start school?
Are there still hurdles we got to get over before that happens?
What's that landscape look like?
Yeah.
Go ahead, Claudel.
Yeah, you know, there is some hiccups, you know, and the process, but we still keep on
going.
We are not stopping.
Yeah.
How does he know there is an issue and political issue in Haiti for now and the embassy is
close.
OK, so we're supposed to wait until it's possible to get the F1 visa.
OK.
And then it seems like we will I will start school in January.
Right.
Amadeus?
Yeah.
So we had a primary plan of starting this fall.
It's the university or I'm sorry, Dixie State University runs on a semester system.
So we're hoping for this fall, which would be an August start date.
But because of the F1 visa and embassy issue, we're going to have to probably kick it down
till spring, which actually starts in January.
And but I think it'll all work out if we can get the reciprocity for his EMT, which we
have a pathway to accomplish.
So he rex done this starting January and then he'll be able to roll right into the paramedic
program, which will start in August of twenty two.
So that's the current plan.
I thought I heard Claudel trying to add something there.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
I was about to say, you know, we will not give up.
It's a long process, you know, and it's life.
It is what it is.
OK.
And because of the hip-hop, that doesn't mean we're going to stop, you know, and as
a mother said, after I will become the first paramedic.
So there will be a few people and two or three or more, you know, we will keep on training,
you know, and the US to become paramedic.
So, yeah, so it's not a single dream, but it's a long process, you know, to help other
people.
And that's what I mean.
Haitian become a paramedic also.
Yeah.
Yeah, that's awesome.
So if there's so there's not any paramedics currently in Haiti, what is the what is EMS
like there?
What level are the providers trained to and like what kind of ambulances are they in or
what kind of service is it?
Yeah, we got cannon villains, which is the national gates for the government.
So it's European.
They are following that European protocols, you know, they got a driver on the ambulance
and a nurse and a first responder.
OK, so that training they receive seems like the same as I mean, any empty, almost the
same.
So the difference is a language.
OK, it's in French.
Yeah.
And MSPP cannon villains got a few ground ambulances.
OK, you know, it's not perfect, but they are doing the job anyway.
Yeah.
And we got a few private ground ambulance services also about, let's say, three of them, which
is a human violence and the salmon villains.
And there is a cross ambulance.
OK, yeah, there is not a lot, but we are still doing the job.
OK, yeah.
So there is no, I mean, critical care.
You know, it's just basic care.
OK, those EMTs, nurses are giving and those ground ambulances.
OK, yeah.
And yeah, that's that's it.
I don't know if you want to add something about this.
You know, you are in Haiti and you see, oh, it's going on.
So you want to add something about this?
Yeah, I think trying to articulate what you're explaining, Cludel, because obviously for
folks who have been in Haiti, we completely understand the picture of what you're saying.
But I think for some maybe EMTs or paramedics who've only worked in the States or in Canada
might not quite understand.
So if I can be as bold to try to articulate a little bit, it's kind of like maybe where
the US was back in the 50s and 60s in terms of pre-hospital care capabilities.
So much of the population still relies on if the person who hit you hopefully stops
and takes you to the hospital.
So I think that's a very common occurrence that still happens in Haiti.
Yeah.
And the infrastructure is so over taxed and just not able to keep up with the population
in the city of Port-au-Prince.
So it's even if you had a fleet of ambulances that were capable, having an ambulance show
up to you within half an hour to an hour is pretty iffy.
And then when somebody does show up, like Cludel said, they're basic level, first responder
level trained folks.
So they're going to throw you in the back of the truck and drive as fast as possible
is kind of the care plan down there.
So yeah.
And having mid-level providers and paramedics would most certainly elevate and force multiply
the system for sure.
You got to have advanced providers to kind of lead the way, show the light and raise
the bar.
So, you know.
And then there are also some of the EMS providers, some of the EMTs and first responder that
you guys have trained who are working in facilities as well, right, in the hospitals?
Yeah.
Mostly at Benhamid Hospital.
And I think there is an organization hospital called GPHRO.
So I think those two hospitals.
So you will find EMTs working.
Yeah.
But besides those two, you will not find any EMTs.
Okay.
It's just going to be first responders, you know.
Yeah.
But no advanced level like paramedic can to beat and to beating people, you know, like
pushing, I mean, knocks.
Yeah.
You will not find those.
So in the ground and the lens.
No.
And then you, Claudel, have most of your experiences at EMT, both in the hospital at Bernard Meves,
there in Port-au-Prince, but also flying with Haiti or ambulance.
Do you want to talk about that a bit and tell us about how you got into that role?
Yeah.
I studied as a first responder 2010 and then 2011, September 2011 became one of the first
EMT, you know, for Haiti.
And right after Amadeus Davidson, I found a job for all of us.
Okay.
At hospital Bernard Meves.
And since that I still working for Bernard Meves hospital as a translator and treating
patient also as an EMT and 2014.
So there was, let's say, Haiti ambulance showed up and they want to hire EMTs and translator.
So I applied for that job and I was one of the four EMTs.
Okay.
They choose to ride along with them.
And yeah.
So I started as the beginner, okay.
At Haiti ambulance.
Okay.
And until now still flying with them.
It was a dream.
And finally that dream becomes true and feel proud to work with Haiti air ambulance and
then helping them, you know, basic stuff and critical stuff also.
Yeah.
Like, and to beating patient and starting IV.
And I remember Ryan care you helped me putting my first you help me.
Yeah.
My first EJ.
Okay.
That was phenomenal.
And it's still doing the same thing.
Okay.
And sometimes they change us role.
You know, we are allowed to start IVs, you know, to yeah.
To do a lot.
Okay.
So I want to move forward, become a paramedic helping more people and then teaching more
people also.
Okay.
And then having the first paramedic class in Haiti for Haiti.
So that's, that's a dream.
And do you have any idea what that process will look like once you finish school?
Because I remember from when I was down there, there was talk about the complications related
to working a paramedic program into the public health system and to getting the Ministry
of Health involved in that.
Yeah.
It was complicated.
You know, government changed from time to times, you know, and you never know when you
will find a good.
Yeah.
Directors, you know, minister.
That's a lot of hard.
But for now, we are working closely with Khan Ambulance and MSPP.
So they want to work with AD ambulance.
Okay.
And AD ambulance also is working in a process to help, I mean, to become paramedic.
And yeah, I mean, that's the day that the ambulance and we are working closely and imagine
Claudel leaving AD and go to United States becoming paramedic.
It's not like individual, the perspective.
It's just for the nation.
It's for Haiti.
And then I will still, I want to work for AD ambulance and I will still be at AD ambulance
and then helping, teaching.
Okay.
Coordinate the first class at AD ambulance.
I mean paramedic class.
Okay.
So it's, and I hope in the future.
So we will still cooperate with Khan Ambulance and the government.
Okay.
To teach the first paramedic class.
And yeah, and still going on still teaching the EMT class.
Yeah.
And how many of you guys are involved in the impact Haiti now?
How many of you instructors are there?
So for now we got, let's see, Claudel, Beninan, Kreme, and we are about five to seven instructors.
And every Thursday we meet together and working on the psychomotor exams.
I mean the EMT psychomotor exam.
So every Thursday we meet together to work on that.
And then I guess the last question I had is what can folks do to help out with this process,
both to get Claudel secured to a C in a paramedic program in the States, but also to help with
like the greater project of training EMS providers there in Haiti?
Well, for Claudel, we have a GoFundMe and we figured between tuition and walk around
money and housing and that kind of stuff, we can get it done for about $20,000 and we're
at about 16,000.
So more than three quarters of the way to our goal.
And so you can visit our GoFundMe page and that's basically just type in Google and
type in GoFundMe and you can say help Claudel go to paramedic school and that'll pop up.
Or the other way is you can just go right to impacthaiti.org.
So E-M-P-A-C-T, Haiti.org and that'll take you to the impact Haiti webpage and it'll
have Claudel's story and a donate button that goes right to the GoFundMe site there as well.
So yeah, so at this point, we're just trying to, well, we've gotten Claudel admitted and
we're going through the process of visa.
And so as soon as we get all that sorted out, hopefully he starts in January and then hopefully
he's graduated.
It'll be around summer, fall of 23 actually, right?
Or 22.
I can't think straight.
Anyway, it's going to be a year once he gets accepted.
So yeah, so if we get him through that program and get him certified and get him back to
Haiti and working, I think at that point we can start entertaining who may be the second
candidate will be.
And we'll just keep working that through impacthaiti.
And so you can go to the website for updates.
And also, we'll throw some stuff out on Instagram, impacthaiti or my Instagram is medicarmadeus.
And I do regular updates on there too.
And is your organization impact Northwest?
That's what it's called, right?
Yeah.
Is that still active?
I'm no longer actually with the organization, but it is active.
They're out of the Seattle area.
I live down in the Southwest now.
And so yeah, that's an organization that I helped start and it's going strong.
We have an incredible USAR team that's active.
It's actually, I believe the only volunteer urban search and rescue team in the country
that's FEMA certified.
And they're still, since Haiti, impact Northwest has been all over the world.
It's all the major events that's happened over the last decade.
So it's yeah, they're doing very well.
My heart has always been with medicine and I just kind of left it in Haiti.
So it's been awesome to be able to come back around and continue on with helping out with
Haiti or Claudel and the gang down there.
So well, it looks like we lost Claudel.
Okay.
But I definitely appreciate it.
Yeah, we'll definitely try and spread the word, see if we can raise the last bit of
these funds and hopefully we can get some people who are interested in helping out whenever
the things return back to Haiti to start training some other folks.
Hey Claudel, you got anything you want to say to the folks that are listening before
we go?
I was disconnected again.
Yeah, but I would say.
Okay.
And then I want to be the one of the first from medic in Haiti.
Hello.
Yeah.
We still got you.
Haiti, everybody.
That's just how it goes.
Yep.
And that's pretty much it.
Thanks for tuning in.
But real quick before we go, just a few shout outs.
First is to pragmatic paramedics, another awesome podcast that we highly recommend.
Next is to the St. Fisher church of evidence-based medicine.
If you don't follow them already, definitely check them out.
These guys, both pragmatic paramedics and the St. Fisher folks have been instrumental
in getting our stuff out there into the world and we truly appreciate that.
And then we'll end things with a shout out to my good friend, Josh Pittman and his buddy,
Kevin Pons.
They put the music together for the show.
Until next time.